in general in order to talk about this
like we have to have a definition 100
but i would say mental illness comes in
all shapes or form that's manipulation
that's control it's right across the
border however you want to see it but
what i would say is that you know
especially women you know you have
really strong women like we would say us
three here very strong women however
things that we may not tolerate or we
may stand up to another woman won't do
that everyone's an individual everyone's
different but we can't sit there and say
just because you retract your statement
or you consent or you say okay actually
this is what happened i've changed my
mind we can't sit there and say we don't
believe you because mental abuse does
exist a hundred percent i'm saying we
need evidence
to
before we make an assumption about
someone but how many times in court like
have you
seen there's been a case and it's been
like okay the evidence has shown the
person's not guilty but really and truly
the person probably is guilty let's be
honest i mean but you have to be offered
evidence i mean i don't know
it's like this it's it's hot it's
especially when you kind of see grape
cases exactly there's not a lot of
evidence that's why a lot of people get
let off and x y and z and people retract
statements so i think it's hard to say
oh let's go to court because you don't
always have that evidence to to back up
what you're saying is true or confidence
as well someone may or may not be
confident enough and as well some women
are embarrassed they feel like you know
i don't want to put all my business out
there in court for everyone to know
what's going on i don't want my business
in the media or for everyone to come up
to me and say xyz and especially if
someone is you know of a certain status
and has certain financial backgrounds
they're thinking i'm scared i don't want
that person to come for me now so they
may retract their statement so
personally speaking like i said before
mental illness does exist and i think
you know we can't sit there and you
can't define it i can't define it okay
what would you do that's not well that's
i don't want to define it i mean it
comes in so many shapes and forms i
don't have to define it but you you but
i'm saying you do if you're going to
talk about it i think anyone mentally i
think comes in a lot of words and forms
and you don't you can't
i can actually but i could see her and
say do you know what abuses
do you know what it is no because the
problem is like the problem is when we
make these broad definitions it like you
you're accusing men of things i didn't
kiss anyone no but when you're when
you're you're saying mental abuse is
real
okay
and you're you're saying that mental
abuse is real and all of these things
happen and it's painting a picture of
men and when you don't define what it is
because even sexual assault and grape
like we don't even have a clear
definition of what those are i'm so
interested about how good no i'm just
really interested how um again in that
statement i mean we were we started off
about you know
what is abuse yeah kind of coming from
that from that point
um and you immediately said that we're
painting a certain picture about men
about you
because we actually grape grape is grape
whether it's men or women men or women
back to your point around what is mental
abuse i think
um you know nailing makes a really good
point about it's very hard to define
mental abuse
um
and i think the reasons why is there's
many different tactics that involve
mental abuse for example
control of finances could be a form of
mental abuse gaslighting so oh you think
this happened no it didn't i'm pretty
sure it did let's run the tapes there
aren't always tapes in life we can't we
can rewind this video we can't do that
abuse that's just a liar
okay so is lying not abuse no i don't
think that's abuse why not i wouldn't i
would define abuse um how would you
define lying what lying not telling the
truth i mean the average person lies
three times a day so i don't think
everyone's abusive in this in the
context of relationships um yeah in
relationships average person the average
person who who are you lying to people
that you have relationships with okay
yeah but in in the context of one person
has more power than the other as a
result of telling that lie if you're in
a relationship when someone decides who
defines who has more power that's part
of the question that's what i'm asking
and this is part of the fun
thing i'm saying i don't i don't think
that lying is mental abuse i think
that's a stretch
okay okay so that's that's your
definition mm-hmm
you see how you see how everyone has
happened
i i think mental abuse i i don't really
know what it is because women use the
terms
no i'm saying it's i don't use the term
like in general i don't talk about it
but i'm saying women use that term so
broadly that i think it's lost the
definition i don't even know what it is
i was going to say ladies
say my suggested to you when's the
difference between good business and
manipulation because let's say you work
in a nine-to-five job and your managers
suggest if you don't do a task properly
you're going to be in trouble so would
you agree that's some form of mental
abuse or does that not make the
the sort because that causes a lot of
stress that could put someone in a
certain way but as soon as we um
come away from the work aspect and it
comes a bit more personal why do the why
do things change in that respect i think
everyone has a motive like you can kind
of throw
with the work example you just had if
you're working in nine to five and if
you haven't done your work which is like
in your contract and there's naturally
there's going to be backlash because
you're being paid to work if you're
taking that same stance for
being at home for example and it's like
your husband or wife said oh if i come
home and the washing up isn't done then
there's going to be consequences but
it's the same concept i'm saying your
manager's saying to you before you even
started the task if you don't do this
you could possibly be fired so is that
not a form of abuse
i think i think i think we obviously
again this is the lovely thing about
having these debates because there's
different definitions right for me
personally i think if it's at the
detriment to someone's human dignity
yeah yeah that's abuse
so dignity is in life then what is your
is your well-being what can't tell me on
the date so yeah i definitely define
that
anyone at work that will tell me
something's going to happen to me before
i've even done it but then we make it a
lot more different when it comes to
relationships and i'm not saying that
that's what you ladies are fighting for
but i just find it interesting that's
what we do as humans
yeah i think humans are super complex
this is why it's a great thing to do
emotional abuse and involves attempts to
frighten control or isolate you
that's what they says online
it's cool so by that definition
everything everyone's kind of said
doesn't fit into it
i wouldn't say lying that would really
fit into it i mean but i mean what's the
line what's the ends
well i think then
and this is why your point about
intention comes up you know
intention what do you mean
so tim was making a point about kind of
like motivation and intention behind
stuff
so i guess
is the lie to
exert a sense of control and power
i think i think intentions is stupid
because you're never going to know
someone's intentions
you can't mind somebody who cares you
can't mind read someone's intentions
right but i think sometimes some people
don't even know how to come in
but i would even i would argue with you
i'd say uh intention does matter like to
say who cares is is not it's not fair
because even like in the law intention
matters like if you slip and fall and
someone dies as a result you didn't
intend to do that you don't go to jail
in the same way that if you plan that so
i think intention matters
figuring that out is a different thing
but it's hard it's i wouldn't agree with
you to say it doesn't matter who cares
yeah yeah i guess because for example
let's say
you're walking and say you're at
carnival um
someone throws a bottle
at you at one of us it hits your head
and then you're oh my gosh i'm i'm hurt
right now and they say oh there's no
intention there there's an accident it
doesn't matter i guess does it matter
how do you feel at that point i guess
you're right in the eyes of the law but
like i just think the results matter
yeah like i don't really give a [ __ ]
like okay if somebody hit me with their
car on accident or on purpose i don't
give a [ __ ]
i got hit by a car
yeah because the outcome is the same so
you're in the eyes of the law sure but
just personally i'm like i don't really
give a [ __ ]
yeah you've hit the nail on the head
there you've hit the nail on the head
because the outcome is the same which is
pain
but let's try this i like that you